to us they are faces to someone they
were family a talented young rugby
player a mother and her teenage son
five-year-old Sean of Flanagan garway
had gone with her dad to buy her mom a
birthday cake Jessica Gallagher was an
up-and-coming designer with her whole
life ahead of her yeah she just turned
24 last week or two weeks ago and she
was gone on to do fashion in Belfast she
just got a new job Belfast
and she was going up yesterday but
unfortunately with the gas explosion she
wasn't able to make it it's eerily calm
at the scene no the investigation into
the explosion ongoing but this tragedy
has had a devastating effect even on
seasoned police officers this does have
an impact on members on garage who have
young children and family themselves and
most of the guards here are local guards
these are the people they work with and
the people that they meet on a daily
basis
there's a palpable sense of loss here
the young and old in this remote part of
Ireland struggling to comprehend the
magnitude of This Disaster
it would be bad enough if this happened
in a big city but this is a coastal
Hamlet of 400 people and they've lost so
many of their own this place known for
its beauty now scarred by Unthinkable
tragedy lives forever changed in an
instant
First Responders who refused to leave
while people remained unaccounted for
say they've never witnessed a community
response like it the local people who
went into that Dreadful scene in their
in their shorts their t-shirts and their
flip-flops they were lifting out
concrete blocks lifting up metal
in an incredibly hazardous environment
incredibly hazardous environment but
they were blinded they were actually
blinded to their own safety
they were blinded by adrenaline they
were blinded by the love of getting into
their friends and their family who are
in there
and they're still doing all they can't
or help their neighbors in small ways
there's this tiny corner of Ireland
prepares to bury its dead David Blevins
Sky News at Chrysler in County Donegal